The
Hello สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะคุณต้อง
สวัสดีค่ะนะเรียนดีนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะถ้ากู
ตามเป็นยังไงสบายดีไหมอ้วนที่ถูกผมเรียบ
ร้อย Home เพราะว่าเหนื่อยมากเลยทำไม
เหนื่อยล่ะเป็นเงินหรอเดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวๆ
เหนื่อยหรือเพลีย
สองอย่างเลย
คือนักเรียนมี 2 คันนะเหนื่อยกับเคลียร์
หลายครั้งที่เราเพลียแต่เราเข้าใจว่าเรา
เหนื่อยอ่ะขึ้นเหนื่อยเนี่ยสมมติว่าเป็น
วิ่งเราไปใช้แรงนั้นไปพายเรืออันเนี้ย
เหนื่อยแต่ว่าเหนื่อยถ้าเกิดเราไปพายเรือ
เราร้อนๆโดนแสงแดดมันก็จะเหนื่อยด้วยแล้ว
ก็เคลียร์ด้วยด้วยกล่องอย่างเลยใช่ใช่แต่
ถ้าแบบนั่งเครื่องบินอีกยี่สิบชั่วโมง
อเมริกามาประเทศไทยใช่มั้ยน่าจะใช่ 20
ชั่วโมงเนี่ยหรือ 19 ชั่วโมงอันนี้จริงๆ
ไม่เหนื่อยนะเลี้ยงร้องเบียร์เพราะว่าไม่
ได้วิ่ง
เรียหรือว่าถ้าเรานั่งทำงานกับ
คอมพิวเตอร์เนี่ย
เคลียร์เนาะ
เลียค่ะอย่ากูต้องนิดเหนื่อยด้วยเพลีย
ด้วยใช่ไหมคะวันนี้ครูต้องอ่ะเหนื่อยด้วย
เหนื่อยด้วยแล้วก็เรียนด้วยเพราะว่ากู
ต้องมาทำกับข้าวแล้วก็รีบทำเร็วๆหลายๆ
อย่างก็เลยเหนื่อยถูกต้องได้ๆเล่า
วันนี้ทำข้าวต้มนิดนึงฮ่าๆๆเพื่อนจะแซว
กันนะคะ
คือตัวเองเนี่ยมีเพื่อนหลายคนที่ที่ชอบทำ
อาหารแล้วก็มีเพื่อนหลายคน
จะขอเป็นคนกินอาหาร
ยังคู่ต้องอีกหนึ่งเดียวได้เราจะมีเพื่อน
ที่ขยันขยันหนึ่งคนที่แบบทำอาหารเก่งมาก
นะคะไม่ค่ะณที่นี้เนี่ยเออพูดถึงเหนื่อย
กับเคลียร์อะเนี่ยกูต้อมเคยมีอาการนี้ไหม
แบบคือแบบอะ
ah ๆไม่มีเวลาคุยกับเพื่อนเอ๋นะคะนะกลาย
เป็น a อ่ะ
นั้นอ่ะเหมือนกันต้อมต้อมนะ
ต้อมอ่ะ
แล้วไม่มีความหมายนะคะนักเรียนเป็นเหมือน
กับเป็นคำค่ะนะจ๊ะแบบเนี้ยอ้ะมันคำที่แบบ
ลงท้ายคำพูดนะฮะที่นี้เอ๋มีอาการนี้ต้อง
เป็นมาประมาณคู่
อาจจะ 6 หรือ 7 ปีแล้วเป็นนะคะเป็นแบบว่า
อยู่อ่ะทำงานใช่นั่งคอมพิวเตอร์แล้วก็ทำ
ทำแล้วก็อยู่ก็ chacha แบบวูบขนาดเนี้ย
โอ้โหแนะนำเข้าใจเขาว่าชาไหมเนี่ยชาคือ
บางทีถ้าถ้าชานะแขนอ่ะก็เหมือนก็
จับแล้วเจ็บๆอ่ะแล้วมันก็ตีปีแล้วก็เจ็บๆ
นึงนะหรือมี
และเอไม่รู้เป็นอะไรอีกแล้วจะบอกชาวุฒิ
ขึ้นมา
กินอะไรเป็นตอนที่เป็นปีแรกก็ตกใจเป็น
อะไรปีที่ 2 ปีที่ 3  a เริ่มสังเกต
สังเกตว่าเวลาที่ทำอยู่ข้างหน้า
คอมพิวเตอร์และทาอะไรเร็วๆน่ะมันจะเหมือน
กับแล้วก็เป็นอาการของการลืมหายใจ
ขอ
หายใจเข้าหายใจออกนะคะหายใจเข้าก็จะอ้า
กินเข้าไปแล้วก็หายใจออกแต่ว่าพอทำอะไร
แบบตั้งใจเนี่ยมันเหมือนแบบรีบๆแล้วมันจะ
เกร็งๆอ่ะแล้วก็ลืมหายใจเพราะลืมไปสักพัก
นึงอ่ะร่างกายเว็บเหมือนกับแกล้งฉัน
ต้องการออกซิเจน
ไก่ตีหรอก
เป็นอะไรอ่ะ a เป็นอย่าลืมหายใจเป็น
อ๊อฟฟิตซินโดมหรือเป็นแพนิคเพราะว่าเป็น
หลังจากที่เอกผ่าตัด
5 ตัดเสร็จมาแล้วประมาณ 1 ปีนะคะสีหน้า
เคยไม่สบายแล้วก็ไปโรงพยาบาลวัดลูกหน่อย
เนาะซื้อจะขอแฉจะกินนิดนึงโอเคคุยแชร์คุย
แชร์แชร์นะคะมาไหมมาไหมยังไม่มายังไม่มา
ทำไมโทรมาทำไมช้า
ทำไมช้า
กูเองไม่เข้าใจส่งเป็นอะไรจ๊ะมาแล้ว
โอเคเห็นไหมต้องเห็นไหม
เห็นไหมคะ
เห็นตามันเหมือนนี่น่ะเหมือนมันโอเคมาน่ะ
ค่ะอ๋อมาแล้วนะโอเค้
[ปรบมือ]
คะแล้วก็มีคุณหมอคุณหมอก็จะมีมีด
เราก็ผ่า
แล้วก็แล้วก็เอาออกพูดมันสนุกแล้วเนาะ
แล้วมันก็จะเดินลำบากเวลาเดินอ่ะเพราะผ่า
ตัดเสร็จแล้วนะเดินมันเจ็บไงก็จะ
หายใจช้าๆหายใจเธอนั้นโน้มหน้าหายใจเข้า
หายใจออกช้าๆแล้วตอนนั้นน่ะเอ้อว่าหลัง
จาก 4 เดือน 4 เดือน 4 เดือนอ่ะ 4 เดือน
เสร็จแล้วก็กลับมาทำงานโอเค๊ไอ้อุดนะคะ
หยุด 120 วันละ 4 เดือน
4 เดือน 4 เดือนที่ที่ไม่ทำงานนะคะลำ
เพราะกลับมาทำงานเนี่ยก็ยังเจ็บอยู่นะฮะ
หลังจากนั้นพอเริ่มดีขึ้นนะคะประมาณสัก
หนึ่งปีมีอาการนี้อาการอาการถ้า
ไม่หายใจหยุดหายใจอีกอ๋อ
น่าจะมีอาการนี้ตอนนั้น
ก็เราจะรู้สึกแบบ
ก็เหนื่อยไหมเวลาหยุดหายใจเราเหนื่อยเนาะ
อันนี้เหนื่อย
แล้วเราไม่รู้ว่าเป็นอะไรจะเลยไปไปไปหา
ข้อมูลใน Google ดูแล้วเขาก็บอกว่าเป็น
ภาวะหยุดหายใจโดยไม่รู้
ขึ้นไม่รู้ว่าเราหยุดหายใจ
ต้องเป็นไหมอ่ะ
เคยเป็นนะคะเวลาที่ทำงานอยู่กับ
คอมพิวเตอร์แล้วเราไปตั้งใจตั้งใจมากๆ
เนี่ยค่ะเวลาที่ใช้เมาส์นี้ค่ะตอนทำ
โปรแกรมที่เป็นเกี่ยวกับอาร์ตเวิร์คทำรูป
นะเราก็จะใช้เมาส์เนี่ยแล้วเราก็จะแบบรู้
ๆๆ
จะ
เลือกทำกรรมฉบับ
ของมันเสร็จรูปปุ๊บว่าขึ้นมาเป็นรูปเสร็จ
ปุ๊บ
เหนื่อยมากทำไมเหนื่อยก็เหนื่อยเหนื่อย
เพราะเราลืมหายใจนักเรียนไม่ออกไปคะเรา
ลืมเข้าใจคำว่าลืมไว้นักเรียนลืมเพ่ยวัน
นี้วันอะไรอ่ะกูต้องวันอะไรกูอีกรึทำไม่
ได้
อาจจำไม่ได้เออเดี๋ยวกู in ดูกันนะอ๋อวัน
นี้วันที่ 10 วันอาทิตย์อย่างเงี้ยอ่ะลืม
นะเหรอลืมนะวันนี้เอ๋ก็ลืมลืมเยอะลืมหลาย
อย่างลืมหายใจไม่ได้นะคะเราจะเหนื่อยให้
กูจะทำงานทำงานแบบกับคอมพิวเตอร์นั้นๆจะ
มีแบบลืมหายใจอย่าทำแบบนี้
ธรรมดาหายใจเข้าหายใจออกแต่ว่าอันนี้
ไม่หายใช่
มันเหมือนคล้ายๆกับเวลาที่เราดูหนังผีค่ะ
ดูหนังผีอีหยังวะเราใช่ป่ะ
เราก็เหมือนจะกันหายใจไม่หายใจกูอย่างนี้
พวกขี่มันโทรมาแล้วก็
ใช่แล้วเราก็จะเหนื่อยใช่ไหม
อันเนี้ยเวลาพูดพูดเอกก็จะลืมหายใจก็จะ
ช่วยหายใจข้าว
ใครจะออกค่ะ
เออโอเค
นะคะอันนี้เพราะว่าเราก็จะบอกว่าเวลาลืม
หายใจเราจะเหนื่อยใช่ไหมคะนายเครียดๆ
เครียดไม่รู้มาดูเราก็จะแบบเกรงใช่ไหม
เพลงร้องบ่าบ้าได้จะยกขึ้นชาย
เหนื่อยนะคะ
เราก็อันนี้จะเป็นจุดเริ่มต้นของอาการ
ออฟฟิศซินโดรมที่ครูต้อมก็เป็นอยู่แต่ตอน
นี้ไม่เป็นแล้วนะขึ้น
ก็คือมันจะเริ่มปวดตรงนี้คู๋ปวดไหล่ค่ะ
ปวดไหล่เขาแล้วนะปวดไหล่สดปุ๊บเนี่ยมันก็
ไม่ป่วยถึงคออยู่ทั้งกฎที่แข็งมั้ยใช่กฎ
แล้วก็จะแข็งเนี่ยกดกดๆฮะกฎบทๆแข็งมากเลย
แข็งเหมือนเป็นไม้เลยนะเนี่ยใครบอกแข็ง
เป็นกระไม้กระดานอันนะไม้ไม้กระดานทำไมมี
ไม้กระดานอยู่บนโต๊ะนะคะเอาไว้สอนนะครับ
อุปกรณ์
โทษนะคะไม่กล้าให้ดูโต๊ะค่ะก็มีทุกอย่าง
มีทุกอย่างค่ะกะละมังยังมีอะไรค่ะคุณทาง
แข็ง
ฉันวิ่งจริงแข็งแล้วก็จะปวดคอนะกูเอ๋แล้ว
บางทีนะมันปวดขึ้นมาถึงหัวเลยนะทำให้เรา
ปวดหัวค่ะเงาะฟิตอินโดเนี่ยขวดอ้างแต่
ไหล่ลายปวดคอแล้วก็ปวดหัวอาเจียน
ไม่อาจเจียมค่ะมีนี้ชัดหัวมันคนเป็น
ไมเกรนเลยก็จะปวดมาที่กระบอกตาข้างเดียว
บางทีก็ปวดข้างนี้คนที่ก็บอก
เขาบอกตาก็คือตรงนี้คุณเอ๋
เฝ้าตากระบอกตาเหมือนกันนะคะแต่ครูเอ๋
เป็นไม่เหมือนชาวบ้านกูต้องคุยเป็นยังไง
ไม่มีปวดหัว
แล้วเป็นยังไงคะไม่มีปวดตรงนี้มีแต่แข็ง
แต่กูอีกจะหลับ
เอาหละคะอันนี้กูเองง่วงนอนแล้วกูยังต้อง
ไปนอนพักผ่อนคือคือคือเหลวเนี่ยมีอาการ
ที่แปลกกว่าชาวบ้านเวลาที่อ่านแข็งนะคะ
บาทแข็งเนี้ย f ปวดเอวเอวหนังปวดดาวว่า
ไม่เคยปวดหัวไม่เคยปวดคอแต่หลับเมื่อไหร่
ที่แบบอยู่อย่างเงี้ยแล้วก็แบบลืมตาไม่
ขึ้นจะหลับเนี่ยรู้ละ
อ้าวรู้นะว่าว่าว่าเริ่มเครียด
เป็นคนที่เครียดแล้วน่ะค่ะอ๋อหนูไม่นะไม่
ปวดอะไรเลยแต่เธอถ้าหลับดีนะกูน้ำก็หาย
ต้องบอกว่ากูเองโชคดีนะดีมากเลยปวดก็ดีนะ
จะได้รู้โอ้มันมาแล้วอาการ
นี่คุณต้องเวลาเริ่มปวดกูต้องก็จะมีแบบ
พวกอย่าอย่าเงียบอย่างนี้กูอันเนี้ยแบบ
เป็นยาเล็กๆเหมือนมีกล่องมันยาวของน้ำ
อย่างนี้เอาไว้ทาอาตัวนะคะถ้าทาตาแล้วก็
นวดนวดนวดที่บีบบีบนวดนวดตัวเองอ่ะ
มันมีอีกตั้งหลายหลายๆวิธีมากที่จะทำให้
เราหายจากอาการปวดทอปฟิต syndome หาหรือ
อาการหยุดหายใจลืมหายใจรู้ไหมใจเวลา
เครียดอย่าลืมนะลืมหายสัตว์กูต้องมีรูป
ให้ดูเองค่ะเชิญค่ะมาค่ะ
อันนี้
ต้องแคร์สกินได้ไม่ได้โอเคมานี่คุยมีวิธี
ที่ 1 อันนี้ฆ่าเอกเคยถามวิธีเขียนเรียก
ว่าฝังเข็มให้กู
ต้องไม่เคยทำนะดีมากกูต้องไม่ต้องกลัวมัน
เล่นเกมมั้ยม่อนไม่วิขุดอ่อมเมื่อก่อนนะ
คะเอกก็กลัวแล้วมีเพื่อนครูคนนึงน้องคน
นึงเขาก็เข้าเด่นวิทยาศาสตร์เนาะเราเขาก็
ออกจากเป็นครูเขาก็ไปเรียนเข็มตอนนี้เป็น
จบ phd เลยนะ
เป็นหมอจีนไปเรียนที่ประเทศจีนตอนนี้เขา
เรียนเรียนเรียนอะไรนะปริญญาตรีฝังเข็ม
มาก
เขาตอนนี้เขาก็มารับพี่เอมาเป็นหุ่น
[เพลง]
กลัวมันก็เก่งมากคือบอกแล้วว่าเอ๋มันจะ
ง่วงนอนแล้วก็ตาก็จะมองอะไรก็จะไม่ค่อย
เห็น
มาฝังเข็มเสร็จแล้วก็น่ากลัวมากกูต้อมแต่
ฝังเสร็จนะโอ้โหแม่นตาไม่ต้องห้าม
หน้าสว่างไม่ได้รีเที่ยวได้ฝังเข็มไม่ใช่
แค่แบบรักษาอาการปวดอย่างเดียวเขาบอกว่า
ฝังเข็มที่หน้าโอ๋แล้วก็จะหน้าแบบ
เอาหน้านะเด็กล่ะเด็กหน้าสวยสวยเลยล่ะค่ะ
อันนั้นไม่เป็นไรเอาแค่อ่าโอเคโอเคแค่ไม่
ปวดเอวไม่นั่งไม่บาปแข็งว่าแข็งๆแล้วง่วง
นอนไม่เอาวิธีนี้กูแอบชอบอยู่ต้อมในชอบ
แต่ว่าตัวต้องเลือกหมอนะคะ
รู้เรื่องของอ่อนมีอีกกูเห็นมีอีกหนูก็
ไม่เคยทำใช่ไหมไม่ค่อยเดียวหรอกต้องลอง
ลองให้คุณต้อมรู้ไหมเอ๋ฝังเข็มเนี่ยนะหาย
อาการเนี่ยประมาณ 8 เดือนเลยนะโอ้โหให้
ฝันเข็มไปแล้วแบบ 8 เดือนไม่เป็นอะไรเลย A
B  B ดีค่ะดีเดี๋ยวมาดูอ่ะวิธีที่ 2 นะ
อยากอุ้ย
[เพลง]
หนูทำไหมคะทำค่ะ
มากเลยแต่ตอนนี้ไม่ได้ไปทำแล้ว
มองเพราะว่าคุณหมอที่จัดกระดูกให้กูเอ๋
เสียชีวิตแล้ว
เอ๋ล่ะเปลี่ยนหมอใหม่สิคือเปลี่ยนเบาะ
ใหม่ก็ไม่เหมือนหมอคนเดิมหมอจัดกระดูกกัน
เดิมเก่งมากนะฮะอุ้ยหมีพูห์ต้องเคยดูใน
วีดีโอนะใน YouTube ในอะไรพวกนี้นะมีเวลา
เขาคุณหมอเขาจัดกระดูกคุณหมอมาจากนี้ค่ะ
แล้วก็แบบ
[เพลง]
โอ้โห
เสียงดังมากเลยอ่ะ
คนไข้อยากก็มันโอ้ย
ทำไมอยโอ๊ยเจ็บนะนี่ค่ะมีมีน้องบีหลายคน
มากที่ร้องโอ๊ยหน้าหลังจากนั้นก็คือพ่อ
สบาย
[เพลง]
เพราะว่าตอนครูเอกไปจัดอ่ะคุณหมอนะคะคุณ
หมอดอนนะเขาจัดแบบทึบแต่แล้วก็กลัวไม่
เก็บเลยมรดรไม่ทำอะไรให้เจ็บเลยแต่ดังภาค
กัดจังหวะดีมาก
แล้วก็ก็คุณหมอจะสอนวิธีดูแลตัวเองมากพี่
ไปหาคุณหมอเนี่ยคือกูเอกเคยเคยนี่มึงมี
อุบัติเหตุกูต้อมถ้ารถ
รถบัสแล้วก็ตกลงมาหัวหน้ากระแทกแล้วก็ไม่
เคยดู
พอกูเองนะเคลื่อนกับเรือนเรากัดเคลื่อน
น่ะมาประมาณหนู
มากกว่า 10 ปิดใคร 20 ปีจากกระดูกหมอแล้ว
หมอก็เลยต้องจัดทั้งหมด 10 ครั้งขอ
ร้านกับจัดเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยกูเอกก็ไปอีก 12
13  14  15 คุณหมอก็บอกพี่ไม่ต้องมาแล้ว
พี่ดูแลตัวเอง
พูดเองหายไหมคะโอเคไหมจริงๆหายนะแต่ถ้า
เราทำอะไรผิดท่าก็กิ๊กเธอชอบนอนดูทีวีแบบ
เนี้ยอันนี้ไม่ดี
ที่นอนไหมเวลาดูทีวีเราก็นอนนะเอาเอาเท้า
คออย่างเนี่ยมีครูต้องแบบจะปวดว่าบางที
ก้มคอดูมือถือแล้วค่ะต้มแบบเนี้ยมันก็จะ
ปวดจากคอไปถึงหลัง
เขาไม่ใช่คุณหมอบอกให้ใช้ให้แบบนี้
ก็บอกให้เราคือขึ้นมาสูงให้มองอย่างนี้
ใช่ไหมนะฮะที่นี่ก็เลยเมื่อยแขน
ไม่เมื่อยคอแล้วนะและเมื่อแขนเสร็จทีสรุป
ว่าใช้โทรศัพท์ลายร้อยน้อยเอาแบบว่าวาง
บ้างพักบ้างนะคะผู้เห็นมีวิธีนึงนะจัด
กระดูกเอกก็ทำฝังอย่างทำๆ 2 อันและ
อันเนี้ยจัดกระดูกกูต้องยังไม่ได้ไปสนุก
ต้อมโอเคขุมวิท 23
วิธีที่ 3 อันเนี้ยกูต้มโอเคนะคะชอบไหมมี
อะไรคะมีนวดเท้านวดไทยนวดสปานวดน้ำมันมี
ทุกอย่างมาบ้างจะคุ้นต้องชอบนวดทุกอย่าง
เลยนะยกเว้นยกเว้น What ขาวทำไมอ้ะสีอ่ะ
รู้จักนะคะครูเอ๋น่ะสีชอบนวดเท้าและครูเอ
เคยนวดเท้าแบบจีนกูต้องเคยนวดไหมอ๋อเคยงด
เท้าครั้งหนึ่งแล้วเขาจะแต่เวลามันคือการ
นวดไทยเนี่ยอ่ะกูเอกก็นวดทำตัวใช่ไหมคะ
ลูกถ่ายนวดทั้งตัวแล้วพอมันว่าที่เท้าอ่ะ
ค่ะเขาจะแบบโหลดลงไปกดลงไปแล้วเจ็บมากก็
เลยไม่ชอบนวดเท้าแอบบอกพ่อบอกเราพูดบอก
ว่าเจ็บๆเขาก็จะนวดเบามันนวดบ่าวตอนแรก
เจ็บๆๆยังไงนี่เจ็บๆไหมคะเขาบอกว่าโอ๊ต
เบาๆเบาๆค่ะเขาก็นวดเบาๆเราไป
สี
แสดงว่าคุณต้องเจอหมอไม่เก่ง
สงสัยหนาเก่งน่ะเขาจะรู้เส้นอันนี้สมมติ
อันนี้มือนะคะสมมุติว่าเป็นฝ่าเท้ากูอีก
ยกเท้าขึ้นมาก็จะไม่สุภาพนะคะไม่ต้องค่ะ
สมมติมือเป็นเท้าเค้าจะมีเส้นใช่ไหมคะถ้า
เขาค่อยๆกดแต่ก็รู้
พอดีพอดีแม่กูตั้มจะไม่เจ็บแต่กู a หน้า
ชอบนวดแบบจีนกินเขาจะใช้ใช้ตรงนี้แล้วก็
กดจะ
เจ็บ
8 เจ็บเสร็จแล้วไม่เจ็บก็น่าคือเจ็บนะ
เจ็บอ่ะเจ็บมากเวลากดเจ็บมากแต่เวลาเข้า
ออกไม่เจ็บขอเอ้ยแปลว่าจองกระดูกเมื่อกี้
กูเองใช่เอาจากกระดูกคู๋ไม่เจ็บนะ
หมอจริงๆเจ็บแต่ว่าถ้าเกิดว่าเขามีไม้
เห็นหน้ากูอีกนี่มั้ยไม่ใช้แล้วจะเกิด
เค้าอันนี้กินเป็นไหมนวดหน้านะคะได้เมีย
ก็เอาหมายเนี่ยเราค่าเส้นน่าจะเป็นแบบนี้
ถ้ากดอย่างนี้โอเคแต่ถ้ากดแบบเนี้ยอันนี้
ต้อมต้องบอกห้ามเพราะมันก็จะไม่เส้นหลุด
ออกมาอันเนี้ยอย่างเงี้ยอย่างนี้กูเองไม่
เอาบอกไม่เอาจะเอาขึ้นลงแบบนี้ขึ้นลงแบบ
นี้นี่มันจะเจ็บแต่ทรัพย์เจ็บแล้วก็ไม่
เจ็บแต่ถ้าอย่างเงี้ยแบบเนี้ยเจ็บแล้ว
เจ็บนานขอ
กูต้องมาชอบ
เอาชาติเวลาที่เราไปนวดเนี่ยต้นๆทั้งตัว
แล้วก็ตรงไหนที่เราเจ็บตู้เดี๋ยวก็บอกเขา
ว่าเบาๆห่านกเวรเนาะๆอารักมะเบาๆเราเบาๆ
คาถาช้าช้าหั่นโอ้นวดเบาๆไม่ตอบ
ไม่เอา
คุณตั้มชอบที่สุดเวลาไปนวดบางทีร้านนวด
อ่ะเป็นร้านนวดไทยนะคะแต่ก็มีร้านนวดสปา
แบบที่มีกลิ่นหอมผ่อนคลายด้วยนะพี่เอ๋เขา
ก็นวดแบบมาผสมผสานการระหว่างนวดไทยด้วย
แล้วก็อารมณ์อ้าด้วยนี่คุยนึงนี่นะอย่าง
นี้นะคะเขาก็จะมีกลิ่นหอมๆหาให้เราดมก่อน
จะหลับก็ให้เราเลือกได้เลยนะคะว่าจะเอา
ตื่นนี้กินนี้กินนี้
1234 เอากลิ่นไหนให้เราเลือกหนึ่ง
เปลี่ยนรู้แต่สปานี่เริ่มต้นนี้เท่าไหร่
นะก็จะประมาณ
1,200
[เพลง]
2200  1500 บาทแล้วแต่ที่เนาะอะไรค่ะ
แล้วแต่ที่ประมาณ 1 ชั่วโมง 30 นาทีหรือ 2
ชั่วโมงจะโอเคค่ะ
ชั่วโมงเดียวมันน้อยเกินไปสู้ดีกว่านะถูก
ต้องชอบทรงชั่วโมงโอ๊ยหลับเลยอ่ะกูเอ๋
อยากกูต้องถ้าไปกูต้องควรจะขัดผิวด้วยไหม
อ่ะ o  o  o ก็มีนะนี่ๆจะบอกว่าอันไม่ชอบ
สูตร
มีแผนเนี่ยนะอลิ r-cooh เอารูปมาจาก
แจ่มจันทร์สมุนไพรนะคะอยู่ตรงเพชรบุรีตัด
ใหม่เนี่ยขออนุญาตนะคะขออนุญาตนะคะเขาก็
จะมีแบบว่าเอ่อ
สมุนไพรไทยเอามาขัดผิวนะคะเวลาที่เรามีดำ
ๆนะคะครูเอ๋อะไรอ่ะก็มีนั้นด้วยเปล่ากู
ต้องเคยดีม๊อบซาวน่าก่อนที่จะมาขัดถ่าย
ใช่ๆเขาก็จะมีอกสาวหน้าอกแบบที่ไอ้น้ำ
ร้อนร้อนๆจริงๆนี่รอเธอหน้าน็
อกสมุนไพร
5 อบสมุนไพรไออุ่นอบซาวน่าอบสมุนไพรนี้
ไม่เหมือนกันนะเพราะว่าเด็กเคยอบสมุนไพร 1
ครั้งก่อนขัดตัวจะไม่ใช่ที่นี้นะคะก็คือ
ปุ้ยไปอบปั๊มเนี่ยเขาร้อนมากเอาหน้าโผล่
มาแล้วก็ออกมาให้คะแล้วก็ไปอบแล้วก็เข้า
มาให้นอกแล้วก็อบพระอบเสร็จปลั๊กโอ้โห
ขาดนี่ขี้ใครนะคะนี่ใครนะคะ
เก๋พี่ใครน้องถูกนะคะนักเรียนมีไหมที่โห
ไม่มีอ่ะออกมั้ยไม่หอเวทถูกที่ใครมันถุง
ให้ดูจะหายที่เค้าไม่ไม่ออกมันเลี้ยงเด็ก
กูอาบน้ำไปแล้วก็อาบน้ำมีสบู่มีอะไรแล้ว
ก็ไม่ออกแต่ถ้าเกิดว่าปกติถ้าเราไปอบอบ
สมุนไพรอ่ะกูต้องแล้วมีขี้ใครเนี่ยจะจะ
ออกดีมากกูเห็นเอ้ยขัดเพ่ยขี้ไคลออกแล้ว
ก็เพราะใหม่ไม่ทำแบบนี้เขาเรียกอะไรนะขัด
ตัว
อ่ะนี่กูเองกูต้องเอาดึงเตรียมดินสอไม้
ขีดนี่ไงอ่ะแอบมองเห็นใช่
นักเรียนขี้ไคลอะเวลานั่งเล่นจะเหมือนกัน
แบบเนี้ยเจอ
คนไทยไม่ชอบนี่ใครต้องฆ่าก็เลยไม่ต้องขาด
หรือไม่มี
แต่ถ้าไม่อบสมุนไพรปุ๊บนะเป่าหูจะร้อน
แล้วก็ sale  sale  sale  4G เป็นเซลล์
ที่ตายอ้ะก็จะขอมาขัดก็จะง่ายกูต้องเช่า
วันนี้ล่ะคะชอบอันนี้มาก
เพราะว่าผมได้ตัดผ่อนคลายเส้น
สบายค่ะแล้วก็อยู่ไหนสูว่าสดใส
อะไรมากนะคะแล้วก็ใช้สมุนไพรไทยในรูปมี
อะไรบ้างอ่ะที่ใช้ในรูปนี้นะคะคุณต้องเอา
มาเป็นตัวอย่างอันนี้ก็จะเป็น
เอ่อน้ำมันมะพร้าวไม่เป็นไรคุณต้องมอง
เห็นอยู่ตรงนี้เองใช่ไหมคะอันนี้เป็นน้ำ
มันมะพร้าววันนี้มาผัดแล้วตัวนี้ให้ผิว
ลื่น
a วันนี้เป็นมะขามเปียกค่ะค่ะสมัยโบราณ
สมัยก่อนนู้นอ่ะชอบใช้ตัวนี้มะขามเปียก
กับขมิ้นหน้าตอนนี้เป็นขมิ้นนะคะๆมะขาม
เปียกในมันทำให้ผิวอ่ะขาวขึ้นมี asa เช่น
ค่าขาวขาวแบบนี้นะคะขาวขึ้น
ส่วน
ขมิ้นขมิ้นนี่ก็แบบทานแล้วจะเป็นสีเหลือง
ๆแบบนี้นะคะเป็นสีเหลืองแล้วก็ทำให้ผิว
พรรณเอ่อสดใสลดริ้วรอยแบบที่ในเหี่ยว
เดี่ยวเป็นรอยตีนกาแบบนี้ค่ะก็จะหายไปเขา
บอกว่าขมิ้นช่วยสมานผิว
สมานผิวคือผิวเราเนี่ยเวลาก็จะต้องที่นี่
แผล
ขมิ้นทาไปแล้วนะแผลเนี่ยจะหายผิวไข่หวยนะ
คนไทยชอบผิวเหลืองด้วยค่ะเมื่อก่อนนะก็
ผ่อนนะคะค่ะมิดหาแล้วเจริญเหลืองนะคะ
เนี่ยชอบไหมคะ
ไม่ค่อยได้ไปกูเอกขัดอยู่ไป 3 คันเองตั้ง
แต่เกิดมาเนี่ยกูเอกไปที่ซุปเปอร์มาเก็ต
นะแล้วกูเองก็ไปซื้อแบบเป็นซองนี่ขัดผิว
แบบเนี้ยนอนแล้วนะค่ะตัวเอง
ผอมเลยนะคุณต้องมาจะขัดเสร็จแหละ 2
ชั่วโมงตัวเอง
หรอคะ
มินิคู๋ไปอ่านเจอ
ไปอ่านเจอมาใน Google นี่แหละเขาบอกว่า
เอ่อถ้าเราขัดตัวขัดตัวเองอ่ะนะอาบน้ำ 1
ชั่วโมง
หนึ่งชั่วโมงแล้วขัดตัวเองทุกอยู่ทุกวัน
เนี่ยอะจะทำให้ผิวดีทำให้สดชื่น
หอมได้โอ้โหโหลที่บอกเอกก็คิดว่าน่าจะ
จริงนะเพราะสมัยเวลากูอีกเป็นวัยรุ่นอ่ะ
กู x ขัดอาบน้ำเนี่ยคือกูอาบน้ำเร็วอาบ
น้ำ 5 นาที 10 นาทีเสร็จน่ะอะคุณป้าป้า
ป้าคือพี่สาวผมแม่จะบ่นทำไมอาบน้ำเร็ว
เป็นผู้หญิงอาบน้ำเร็วไม่ดีไปอาบใหม่แล้ว
ก็ขัดขอ
เอกขัดขี้ไคลเพราะจะโดนเช็คเช็คหูเช็คคอ
เล่นอาบนานๆๆๆก็ขัดขัดขัดตอนนั้นผอมค่ะ
อายุน้อยด้วยหรือเปล่าไม่รู้ไม่ใช่เมื่อ
กี้คุณต้อมหัวเราะครูเอ๋เดี๋ยวนักเรียนจะ
งงว่าเอ๊ะครูต้องหัวเราะอะไรเพราะว่ากู
ต้องคิดว่าเมื่อก่อนกูต้องอ่ะถ้าเหนื่อย
เวลาขัดขัดขี้ไคลคุณต้องตัวเล็กขัดแป๊บ
เดียวโอเคแล้วตอนเนี้ยไม่ใหญ่เหมือนภูแอบ
พูดเลยว่าตัวใหญ่ขึ้นแล้วก็ขาดนาน
ตัวใหญ่นะน้องขัดทุกวันกูต้องคือคู๋น่ะ
ไม่ได้ขัดมา
นานไม่กินภาวนาน่ะนานนอนว่าคือมีสบู่นะๆ
แต่ถ้าขาดเนี่ยมันต้องอย่างนี้เลยนะนัก
เรียนต้องอย่างเงี้ยอย่างเงี้ยกลายเป็น
นวดตัวเองอ่ะคือเราโดนสอนให้อาบน้ำด้วย
กันนะว่าตัวเองแบบเนี้ยขาดแบบนี้เลยฮะขัด
น่ะขาในต้องรถใช้เวลานาน
อะไรคะถ้าทำอย่างนั้นถ้างั้นกูต้องคิดว่า
เราควรจะทำอาทิตย์ละครั้งดีไหมคะหนูให้ทำ
ทุกวันไม่เอาเราก็รีบ
ถ้ามีเวลาได้นะครั้งเหอะโอเคเราเริ่มเถอะ
ก็เดี๋ยวนี้ไปอีกนะอาบน้ำ 5 นาทีเสร็จใช่
แล้วเราไม่ต้องไปที่สปานะเราทำที่บ้านเรา
นี่แหละ
ประหยัดด้วยไป Spa  1 คันไว้ใช่ไหมคะทำ
ที่บ้านก็
200 บาทซื้อไม่ไม่เกิน 200 บาทบางทีก็
100 บาทซื้อที่เป็นสมุนไพรเป็นซองมาหากู
เองกูเองนี้มะขาม
แล้วก็เก๋ค่ะมินแต่น้ำมันมะพร้าวเองก็เอา
มาผสมเองอีก
[เพลง]
ดีเกียรติอ่ะผสมเองดีแล้วนะจริงๆง้อเก๋
รู้จักอะร้านที่เขามีมีเป็นอะไรขมิ้นมี
ไพรสำหรับผิวอะ
เดี๋ยวมากคุยเกียจทำไงอ่ะและก็จะไม่ได้
ขาดอีกเพราะฉะนั้นไปซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตแล้ว
ก็ไปซื้อที่เขาเป็นซองขายเนี่ยกูเอ๋ฝากมา
ค่ะนายมากข้อเสียของเราคือเราขี้เกียจขี้
เกียจแต่เรายังห่วยอยากจะบาย
คือจะจะทำก็ต่อเมื่อ
เหนื่อยมากๆไม่ไหวแล้ว
แต่ว่าการที่เป็นนวดแบบนี้นะคะที่เราพูด
กันตั้งแต่ต้นชั่วโมงว่าเราลืมหายใจลืม
แล้วเหนื่อยเนี่ยก็เราไปนวดน่ะเราก็จะรู้
สึกรู้สึกอะไรผ่อนใครยังนะรู้สึกจากบาย
แล้วก็จะหายใจข้าวให้เราหลับอ่ะค่ะหลับ
แล้วก็จะหายใจใช่ไหมธรรมชาติเราไม่ลืมหาย
ใจนะคะเวลาหลับเนี่ยไม่ลืมค่ะแต่ถ้าเราทำ
งานเราจะลืมหายใจ
จริงๆบางคนโป้โยคะนะคุณต้องโอ้โยคะก็ดีนะ
คะบางคนก็เล่นโยคะก็ช่วยได้
ไม่ค่อย
อายใจเข้าจะๆหายใจออกคชา
มีอย่างอื่นอีกคุณต้อมร้องเพลง
ร้องเพลงต้องเลือกเพลงดีๆนะคะเอาเพลงเบาๆ
ผ่อนคลายอย่าไปร้องแบบว่ายก
ไม่ได้นะคะเหนื่อยอีกครั้งไม่แต่ว่าเป็น
การปลดปล่อยนะปลดปล่อย Oh นักแสดงว่าเรา
เครียดมากแล้วก็ต้องจับ
อย่างนี้หรอคะคู๋ให้ใช่ a นะอยู่ในห้อง
น้ำอ่ะแล้วก็ร้องเพลงโชคดีคล่องครั้ง
เนี่ยเขากลับเยอรมันไว้ล่ะ
ตัวอยู่เนี่ยอ่ะก็คงจะกลับๆๆ
อุ้ยเราก็ต้องขับรถไปที่ต่างจังหวัดทั้ง
คู๋ไปที่ทุ่งนาขว้างแล้วเราก็ไปตะโกนดังๆ
ๆ
ไปที่ภูเขาก็ได้
อ๋อมีอีกเทคนิคกูต้องขอหน้าว่างได้
ไหมได้ๆคู๋นักเรียนบอกว่าฉันไม่มีเวลาไป
ตะโกนวรรณภูเขาฉันจะทำยังไงนี่ๆ
มีวิธีพิธีของคนไทยคนนึงเขาสอนหากาละมัง
หรือหาขันก็ได้ค่ะแล้วก็ใส่น้ำเปิดไฟน้ำ
อาแล้วก็เอาหน้าตัวเองลงไป
ทำยังไงอีกแล้วก็
เนาะโอเคเดี๋ยวต้องไปลองดูแล้วไม่มีเสียง
ไงกูต้องขึ้นเราต้องหายใจเข้าออกเข้าลึกๆ
นะฮะแล้วก็จะเอาหน้าน่ะแต่กันที่นั้น
มันจะมีค่า
ออกมาโอเคโอเคเราแปลว่าเราออกเสียงเต็ม
ที่และ
ช่วยได้ดีมาก
เห้อกูเห็นไปลองทำ
นักเรียนเอกเครียดเหรอคะอ๋อไม่ใช่อันนี้
มันออกกำลังกายปอดทำให้หายใจเข้าหายใจออก
สบายขอให้ถ้าไม่ได้ไปนวดเพราะตอนนี้อัน
นี้ไปยากใช่ไหมคะถ้าไม่ภูเขาไปยืนที่ภู
เขาถ้าไม่โยคะก็เอามานี่
โอ๊ยกูเอ๋คุณต้องไปที่รถไปที่รถแต่ไม่
ต้องขับไปไหนนะข้างอยู่ในรถปิดหน้าต่าง
ปิดประตูแล้วก็ ago ในรถก็ได้
กูต้องลองทำแบบนี้กูต้มจะรู้สึกว่าต่าง
กับอยู่ในรถ
และก็รอโอเคโอเคตอนไหนรู้มั๊ยก็มีน้ำมี
น้ำแล้วก็จะเย็นแล้วก็สดชื่น
ลองดูลองดูๆได้ว่าละร้องตั้มจะหมดเวลา
แล้วเอ๋มึงต้องปิด screen ก่อนนะ
ข้านักเรียนวันนี้กูต้องกับครูเอกก็มี
วิธีมาแนะนำนักเรียนถึงการเข้าเล่นกัน
รักษานะไม่ใช่รักษาบรรเทาภาษาไทยได้
บรรเทามันโง่อาจจะการ
อ๊อฟฟิตซินโดมหรืออาการลืมหายใจนะนะคะทำ
ให้เราผ่อนคลายเนาะไงกูก็จำแฮปปี้มีความ
สุขกับการทำงาน
นายมาเดี๋ยวกูจะเอามาคุยไปตะกั่วในน้ำ
ก่อน
โอเค
ปลาถ้าเราไม่เป็นกันดีกว่านะคะนักเรียน
นักเรียนไปก่อนไฟแบบไหนก็กินคอมเม้นมาขอ
ให้ฟังกันบ้านนะคะรู้มีวิธีแนะนำเราไหมคะ
ว่านอกจากฝันเข็มหนูนวดมีอะไรอีกนะตัด
กระดูกกระดูก
ร้องเพลงอ่าขัดผิวผิว
ทำอะไรได้อีกองค์
ทำอะไรนะคะ
ขอบคุณนะคะคุณเอ๋คุณต้อมขอบคุณค่ะนัก
เรียนบ๊ายบายนะ